you guys catch that trip because that's
a really important part of what to talk
about so I'm Christina Tosi I am the
pastry chef and owner and founder of
Momofuku Milk Bar I am a crazy dessert
person I loved eat dessert I love to
make dessert I love to talk about
dessert I love to share dessert I was a
home baker long before I decided to
become a pastry chef by profession I
decided that I just in my fiercely
competitive spirit and loving dessert so
much that I'd go to New York City the
most competitive place you could get
into in the most brutal kitchens and I
would attend culinary school become a
pastry chef but being a pastry chef back
then was being the pastry chef in a
really fancy restaurant and a four-star
restaurant so I moved to New York I went
to culinary school and I fiercely
competitively worked my way into the
most competitive kitchens and I realized
as I was making my way to the top that
you know I was the person that got to
make the really fancy cocoa nib tuile
and place it just so on the plate of
this like single orange and chocolate
fondant with passion fruit coulis when
really I was just like oh my god I can't
wait to get home to put that like knob
of oatmeal cookie dough in the microwave
for 30 seconds and just eat it like
gooey and half way melted in my pajamas
and so I started stepped back and I had
to really think about what that was and
why what I had chosen to put myself
where I had chosen to put myself Dave
and I met and obviously for really
strange reasons we get along we see
eye-to-eye for no specific reason other
than we sort of just are similar people
and parallel paths
I loved that Momofuku had the spirit
about it and that it was comfortably
human it was competitive and all of
these other parts of me that made so
much sense it was a little scarred from
the fancy pastry kitchen so I started
working for Dave in this completely on
pastry related capacity I was helping do
office work and operational stuff and
somehow I wedged myself into the kitchen
or Dave forced me into the kitchen
knowing that I had pastry background but
also knowing that there weren't desserts
on
any of the MOOC restaurant menus I found
myself sort of back in this place where
I was like man I'm back in the kitchen
and not only am i back in the kitchen I
need to make desserts for these menus
that anything could go on the menu so I
thought all right I'm going to just pull
all the people I work with people whose
palates I trust people who is opinion
and approach to food I trust I'm just
going to ask them what their favorite
dessert is at a restaurant and maybe
that'll just at least put me on a path
so I asked what's your favorite dessert
was asking the fanciest people I knew
thinking that if I was going to make
desserts for a restaurant I was going to
have to really make these really really
fancy desserts losing sort of my
trajectory so if I ask you guys what are
your favorite desserts we just shout out
a few out it could be anything
ice cold chocolate chip cookies ice
cream right so guess what I got from
these guys the same thing banana cream
pie lemon poppy seed cake McDonald's
fried apple pie and I'm like you are the
culinary pedigree and that's what you
got for me versus her like that's oh my
god I'm in trouble then I realized that
I was trying too hard again and all of a
sudden I was like oh look I know this
because I work at Momofuku good food is
good food it doesn't have to come with
pretense it doesn't have to be anything
it just has to be something that makes a
connection with you and all of a sudden
being a home baker first was something
that I wasn't trying to steer away from
and I wasn't trying to honor the sort of
fancy culinary education that I had it
was about combining both of those things
so I made some desserts and put them on
the menu and it went pretty well and
then I opened milk bar for me it's about
giving food back in a really simple
comprehensible vehicle that when you see
it you want to eat it from a user
standpoint you know that it looks good
you know that it's going to taste good
the second you bite into it you know
it's delicious and that's all you need
to do from a consumer standpoint well my
job is is to take the inspiration and
deconstruct it and figure out how I'm
going to put all my skill and experts
whether it's from the home baker in me
or the culinary professional in me and
do all of the toiling and troubling of
how I'm going to get it back to you in
the most simple recognizable
user-friendly and delicious manner some
of the most popular items hid in milk
bar are as follows
cereal milk is what's left in the bowl
if you eat all the cereal out of it and
we swirl it up into a soft-serve ice
cream and we put it into every single
thing that we can think of another big
popular vote for item is called crack
pie and has a toasted oat crust and a
gooey butter filling and for those of
you that are familiar with the st. Louis
gooey butter cake it's also in a mosh to
that which is a big staple in my
childhood the compost cookie no one
makes a better choc chip cookies of my
grandma that's all there is to it and no
matter how great of a pastry chef I am
there's no way I know how to make a
chocolate chip cookie that's better than
your favorite chocolate chip cookie
because you already have that
relationship with it so I was like well
we're going to make cookies people love
cookies but we're not going to make a
chocolate chip cookie because that's
dumb why would I make something that
already exists and that people already
love in their own right
so the compost cookie it has pretzels
potato chips oats chocolate chips
butterscotch chips graham crackers and
coffee grounds and then we make layer
cakes and the chocolate chip cake is
passionfruit coffee and chocolate which
is like a really fancy pastry chef
triumvirate of flavors that I was like
I'm gonna instead of being fancy with it
I want to bring it down into this funny
little layer cake and we build the cake
in this very sort of constructive
architectural way because that's what
pastry chefs do that's what you're
trained to do as a pastry chef but
rather than hide all of the fillings and
these textures and layers that we dream
up we keep the outside of the cake
exposed so you can tell how much time
and effort and work goes into it we with
our eyes before we eat with our forks or
hands and so we have this sort of
elaborate process of layering up this
chocolate chip layer cake we make 14
different flavors of layer cake and
every single one of them has a really
simple starting point every single one
of our desserts has a really simple
starting point whether it's a chocolate
chip cookie whether it is a birthday
cake whether it's ice cream
whether it's cereal milk ice cream
and that is sort of my approach on
Momofuku terms and on my own terms of
how I design desserts steal the show